[Music]
time now for final exam where you pit
our friends here at fox against one
another figure out who's been paying
attention to the news this week joining
us tonight
a beast otter Associated Real Clear
Politics and Fox News correspondent
Griff Jenkins both have done this show
before both have won before which is the
pressure on tonight's contest there she
is she's brought maybe started even
defending champ yeah I won last week and
so you like last year so same for always
brilliant win found the smartest woman
in Washington why did she go against let
him come back to win two weeks in a row
adjusting expectations a grip Jenkins
your wise man you know the rules both of
you but for our viewers who may not
remember them
handsome buzzers I ask the questions
first one to buzz in gets to answer the
question you must wait until I finish
asking each question in order to buzz in
and four correct answers worth the point
each incorrect answered attracts a point
from your total tragically but those are
the rules
best of five wins are you ready trying
to be trying to be that's good enough
for us question one according to the New
York Post America's greatest newspaper
which Hollywood Trump hater is facing
legal trouble due to over so sized
donations she once made two Democratic
candidates Kris Jenkins Roseanne Barr
Roseanne Barr
he's trying to lose Rosie O'Donnell you
get to answer Roseanne Barr roll the
tape got the wrong Rosie Rosie O'Donnell
under fire tonight for what appears to
be an illicit campaign contribution to
at least five Democratic candidates
exceeding the maximum amount allowed
under campaign finance law boasting in a
tweet today all my donations my goal is
to support all those opposed to Trump
after decades in Washington your
conspiracy minded analysis was he's
trying to lose yeah I know and I've lost
contact with this I need to buy my good
luck sling is just a little rusty yeah
what army Beach let's say he was wrong
wrong referee good point question to his
multiple choice this week California
became the first US state to mandate
that some residents do what a compost
be recycle or C go solar
Grif Jenkins wants to go solar si go
solar - the tape we go in a
controversial move the state of
California now mandating that beginning
in 2020 the majority of new homes and
apartment buildings be built and just
that's the analysis so did you know the
answer the correct answer of course I
did yes you did
but for the second time in a row you
lost it because man his his heat of his
palm with the buzzer there's something
going on there race the negative number
so we're back to parody now zero zero
going into question three are you ready
here it is which ride-sharing company
this week unveiled plans for a flying
taxi maybe yes uber uber uber is it uber
uber will pitch its plans for are you
ready for this 200 miles per hour and
use helicopters style rotors to take off
and land
wow that was icy cold you moved right
into the lead position no trace of
emotion I'll take the Jena Hospital
hearings for 500 question for another
multiple choice this week Google
unveiled a brand new feature in which a
robot assistant will do which everyday
tasks so that you don't have to is it a
shop for your food be make your phone
calls or C Drive your car Grif Jenkins
be make your phone calls make your phone
calls is the answer is that correct it
seemingly creepy artificial intelligence
that can make dinner reservations for
you
[Music]
going into five it is tied the outcome
of this question to determine oh I'm
looking for pressure okay are you ready
this is question five some actual news
this is actual news the LAPD the police
department in Los Angeles America's
second largest city says a famous shoot
that Robert Downey jr. wore in a
Hollywood film has been stolen the
estimated worth of this suit is $300,000
what is the suit let me repeat what is
this - not the lawsuit the suit of the
outfit is in fabric as in fabric but
what suit is it this is a mutant named
are saying that we can give you what a
superhero movie is Ferris Bueller's
superhero is Ferris Bueller's Day Off
is it the suit that he would see in that
movie Amos Lee in the superhero film be
Ferris Bueller's Day yes it was in the
sequel but we'll see if that's correct
roll the tape I think we need some new
questions the original Iron Man suit the
one Robert Downey jr. wore in the first
movie was stolen the suits were
reportedly worth $325,000 the sketch of
the suspect if you see anyone who looks
okay so I'm gonna ask the judges the
correct answer was Iron Man will early
take Ferris Bueller's unfortunately the
judges that I'm quoting we're not gonna
be able to take clothes ABS that was
valiant many were rooting for you but
the one-armed Phenom won once it's
unbelievably thinkin's ladies and
gentlemen congratulations to you I've
got the better mug anyway I don't know
they're giving out new loss with such
grace and style this for you this is our
air Temple mug drink it with pride
that's it for this week's final exam pay
attention to every news item no matter
how obscure this week and tune in on
Thursdays see if you can beat our
experts we'll be right back